you're a blessing Mr Clay this place was
crab grass and weeds and you brought it
back to life Mrs Parker and I were
friends she was the only person who ever
took care of any I just got a message
saying that there's a problem with my
computer yes ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm count to three one two
three there I did it for
you you take it I'm going to burn this
place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
beekeepers is a special program outside
the chain of command I protect the hive
when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have laws for
these things until they fail then you
have
[Music]
me my fingers they cut them off oh come
on bro don't
move
bow down
for this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scam the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem cut them
right I'm a
problem I figured to give the
firefighters a break somebody detain
this
guy
we have to kill him before he kills his
way to the
top
honey it's flammable oh
no